es probablemente el chiste más caro de
toda la historia el Ministerio de
cultura en puesto la multa de casi 15
millones de yuanes más de 2 millones de
dólares a una empresa de entretenimiento
de Shanghai por el chiste de uno de sus
humoristas este durante fin de semana en
una de sus actuaciones se había dicho
que al ver a dos perros callejeros
persiguiendo a una ardilla la había
venido a la cabeza la célebre frase Ten
una buena ética de trabajo y prepárate
para pelear y ganar batallas es la frase
que pronunció el presidente y referencia
al ejército de liberación popular años
atrás uno de los asistentes acudió a las
redes sociales para decir que se había
sentido incómodo y desde entonces el
debate sobre los límites del humor a
monopolizado tanto internet como los
medios de comunicación el debate ha
terminado esta mañana con esa multa por
difamar la gloriosa imagen del ejército
según el Ministerio y con las disculpas
tanto de la empresa como del humorista
que por cierto ya ha sido despedido el
ejército es una de las instituciones más
queridas en China no es especialmente
brillante en el campo de batalla pero no
admite rival en las tareas de rescate
Durante los desastres naturales es por
eso que se ha generado grandes simpatías
desde el 2021 hay una ley que prohíbe
los comentarios y respetuosos hacia el
ejército y de hecho un periodista ya
pasó siete meses en la cárcel por decir
que la imagen quedaban los militares
chinos en una película propagandística
era estúpida este incidente ha subrayado
los terrenos movedizos en los que se
mueven los humoristas aquí en China
Especialmente los que se dedican al
estándar comedy un fenómeno cada vez más
arraigado aquí tanto en las televisiones
como en Los pequeños bares es habitual
que sus monólogos tengan que pasar por
la censura para recibir el visto bueno